yeah verse two then another side I'm
gonna do it myself whenever I ride you
know my brothers what do you do is baby
this is what do you want we go G hat
weak-ass Gucci and weak as Gucci hey
let's go down to this little punk ass
gucci belt but we don't come right here
and then notice how you get one side I
like to shop in pieces I just get pieces
and I put them together I really don't
care you know what I mean I just I just
go with my move I mean the way clothes
fit guess what I put the most
interesting when this wrist I got to
Cuban link bracelets one of them to Tony
rose gold white gold on this one I got a
P I'm saying - Tom P boy ok bracele
giving us an when we got the Newkirk
piece you know I give to myself and I
got like another little Cuban League I
got this hit up under there when it
comes designer brands I like Gucci I
feel like I got the most options like
from what I like like right now like I
like loud
we're good [ __ ] I want you to know this
[ __ ] you get what I'm saying
I want you to see that and cross the
street that Gucci you know and then when
I feel like being more subtle than
column with it then I do that but right
now I feel like it Gucci hours you know
it's good I'm not fighting nobody else
you get what I'm saying I'm just doing
me you know I like to work for this
Chagas you know I mean I thought with
Jersey on put a t-shirt up on there to
feed it whatever we can go your way and
I like to show off my arms I'm pretty
chocolate skin so like at one point like
how is my bond in New Jersey like every
day do you ever tested fit out before
going on public for show everybody look
in the mirror change outfits by six
times
like you know certain days sometimes I
just noted here that you know boom
whatever feel right you feel good I was
traveling from I think that Lana back to
Charlotte at this show and I was just
thinking like how hard this being like a
baby sweats with and you know how to
write forces always you can't lose
weight especially when you got a splash
away that song and I covered it popped
like that purple I looked like a better
version of Barney and I mean Barney used
to be my dog - when I was a baby
yeah I like that like that a lot I got
on the baby Jesus scheme add my logo on
it but you can't see his road up so
that's actually a scheme at I think
that's our money exchange Swisher some
orange Nike joggers and I forgot with
them shoes God ain't Nikes I forgot what
they call it oh I think it's I'm sort of
MX I like colors they pop I post a lot
people like a lot of people oh my god
just mix throw what you got tasteful but
I look better in person believe it
alright killed sit on my boy Bobby
Wesley I killed
I killed my forgot with that suit was it
something like that Valentino's some I
keep James hat and those are Louis V
loafers by the way and got little bees
although I had to cut up on the carpet
watch how he come this Friday and hit by
boy
probably mode I was like yes I'm go by
when they want to go viral is gonna drop
music and they're gonna see everybody do
what you want to do it don't matter you
know you look how you feel somebody
today you look how you feel what I do is
the baby this is what are you wearing
listen to my new album Kurt right now